foreign
people welcome to a live unfiltered
episode of Australia commentary raw yeah
you feel that edge because we're talking
about the edger tomorrow uh honest
trailers on screen junkies right now go
watch it come back here and watch us
watch it and give you our behind the
scenes thoughts about the film
um we also have q a with you the fans so
put those questions in the uh chat to my
left or right uh depending on what
hemisphere you're in and then
um we'll also show you outtakes and then
we'll tease you with a clue for next
week's honest trailer uh let's Dive
Right In Edge of Tomorrow it's a good
film
yeah yeah I like this one
um gosh I was looking up at Doug lyman's
filmography that guy up and down some
ups and downs up and downs yeah it was
such a hot start with the swingers go
born yeah that's an awesome story he
also doesn't get his flower swingers is
so commonly now remembered as the the
Favreau Vince Vaughn kickoff yeah I
think people forget that it was also
Doug why not there's like some real
Direction going on it doesn't look like
a TV show exactly it really looks like
an indie like a film yeah so great start
go was fantastic
um underrated a lot of people you don't
recall uh show up and go yeah well that
was like I feel like that was the first
time uh Timothy Oliphant stuck out to me
all the fan where I was like that guy's
good when's he gonna be more stuff
what's her
what's her name something McCarthy oh
Melissa McCarthy Melissa McCarthy's and
go oh I didn't remember that there's
some great so anyways yeah enter
tomorrow is great
um
we were just jumping over Mr and Mrs
Smith directly to Egypt tomorrow yeah uh
uh Tom Cruise like this is uh this is
probably one of his best films uh top
five you know what I think this is
probably his fifth best film I would say
I feel like you need a guy like a cruise
he's so dedicated to like to to story
and confident in his own presence
because this is not a character I feel
like most movie stars would want to play
because he's a coward he's a he's he's
he's AWOL he's trying to get out of his
military service that's why every other
character in the movie is coming down on
him so hard and I feel like that's the
thing like we always hear about the Rock
and Vin Diesel and all these guys like I
have to look so tough like I have to get
this many punches in I have to win all
my fights and I have to like be the
archetypal hero the whole time and I
love that Cruz is like I'll be like kind
of a scumbag he learns his lesson I'd
say that like with a Few Good Men and
like Jerry Maguire I guess he's not
afraid to play like a sniveling weasel
at the beginning of a film who grows
character grows because he knows that
right I'm gonna Arc and I'm I'm Tom
Cruise so I will sell you on this Arc
and by the end you will love me anyway
even though I'm kind of skis in the
beginning and I like I really admire the
confidence so when you combine that with
um the premise of the time Loop and I
think they use that really effectively
to basically as we say like cut all the
fluff and extraneous information out of
what generally uh slows down an action
movie and they just get to the good
parts they just get to the funny part
they use it it's funnier than I
remembered because a lot of times they
use the time Loop premise like to get
laughs of like squishing him yeah the
editing in the the pacing of it is
really good and they use the right the
the time Loop stuff very effectively is
a punch line a lot like and I really
like how they knowingly kind of skip
over all the really gratuitous scenes
you'd get in a movie like this like they
know we're anticipating them and they
jump over them purposefully like one of
my favorite scenes of the movie is
there's this whole conversation about oh
they're gonna have to break into
Whitehall this like British military
installation and go you know break into
break into the General's office this
because they've got to convince him of
their plan and he's not going to want to
see them uh and you're you you know
every other movie how you would do that
we get a montage we have the diagrams
they roll out the blueprints all right
so the guard here we got to go here then
you're gonna you're on the electrical
intercutting it with it like doing the
prep work and like scouting it out and
they very perfectly the you smash cut to
Cruz and Emily Blunt walking up to the
building he's already done his ten
thousandth try right he's he's groundhog
dated through and learned everything
that happened so he's just going through
it like wait two seconds that I think
right okay now we proceed and you get to
skip all the stuff that the gratuitous
stuff that we know what would happen
anyway and it's like man that is
effective storytelling that's really
good upend my expectations like that and
jump jump to the good stuff very very
tight script by Chris McCoy yeah yeah
McHugh as he's called so frequently
McHugh vs McGee what Mick do you have
well Big G that was like I don't know
that guy's real name like he's just
McGee I thought that was it yeah like he
was born like he was just born into the
McGee's they were like no first name
he's just Big G but no he's Christopher
he goes barbecue because I guess
Christopher requires a long name hmm I'm
trying to think of like is Ian McKellen
McKay okay that's what I would call him
if I knew him oh Adam McKay can we say
McKay McHugh McGee movie fight uh sound
off in the comments below number one
McHugh number two uh I'm McKay or Mickey
I don't know Michael McGee on that one I
don't know man weirdly McGee and has
Adam Doug Lyman both did uh early
episodes of the OC yeah I think if you
cut off McKay before things got too
serious like he said Brothers Talladega
because of course I put him up yes he
beats McGee but if you're if you're
including uh
don't look up yeah uh all right let's
let's watch it tomorrow that's a movie
we all like yeah there you go
you've seen the time Loop premise work
well for comedies horror or really
anything
but it turns out when you try to
Groundhog Day in action flag that
usually kicks ass too
Edge of Tomorrow us before Christmas
source code very good yeah I don't know
I I like it until it kind of runs out of
steam I feel like as a there's a train
pun right there I didn't even mean to do
that but yeah Looper very good last
level I haven't seen but oh I like
people seem to like it boss level
actually is it's mostly gorilla I like
Frank Grillo is very fun to watch at a
premise like that he's both got a lot of
personality and he's like believable in
the action stuff so I think and you have
Mel going full metal you you get the
full metal that's a lot of mail it's a
lot of Mel but uh yeah so I feel like
more so in that case than the cleverness
of it is just because that really is
just pure video game rules like it's
purely like he just respawns from the
save point yeah and like go uh so it's
less clever than this one but but it is
it is a lot of fun yeah just as a
template for action or horror or comedy
it seems to be just a narrative trick to
get rid of anything you don't want to
put in your movie because you can skip
it it lets you just jump around to like
the fun the fun stuff and it's it's a
good like again it's a good set up for
like a setup punchline kind of editing
and like is there any genre that has not
been subjected to the time Loop premise
yet hmm I'm going to go like historical
biopic I don't feel like we've got
well not historical but um that
Wachowski movie where Tom Hanks plays
everyone Cloud Atlas yeah it's kind of
like a Time Loop man they're no those
are different stories happening at
different points of time but they're all
connected through mysterious uh ethereal
ways okay keep going
before Chris McCrory made it his
lifelong goal to kill Tom Cruise on the
job Doug Lyman made a half-ass go of it
an edge of tomorrow the ultimate movie
for people who love Tom Cruise or hey
Tom Cruise I think I broke something oh
hold on hold on listen I can still feel
my toes
okay do it in this underrated Jam that
goes by Live Die Repeat on DVD but is
actually based on the Japanese manga all
you need is kill come on movie you've
got Mech suits Buster swords and a
tentacle monster embrace your anime as
self now he needs the mad scientist
who's there to do the exposition and
give you the hero's magic McGovern they
can use to stick it into the alpha and
it Taps into the wavelength connecting
it to the Omega ah so does nay
uh that's the thing that people know
about this movie is like the name kept
changing right
um Edge of Tomorrow it's not a bad name
but I mean I get it but all you need is
kill is so much better I don't know why
you would change all you need is kill
two Edge of Tomorrow it's less
interesting yeah it is interesting in
that it doesn't fully read as
grammatically correct oh it does not at
all I think that's what's fun about it
okay
um yeah so I wonder I wonder why they
why they swapped it out because I guess
it must have underperformed given their
expectations yeah they were like okay
well let's change the name for just the
video release like oh that yeah I I
think uh when the movie came out it
underperformed in theaters and I think
that yeah that became like the well
people didn't know what Edge of Tomorrow
meant or it was obscure it didn't make
sense or whatever and so I think but
that that I think that got the blame but
I don't think that was probably what
actually was at fault yeah titles are
tough and this is why um they just gave
up and made every uh movie based on a
product you've heard of because it's
about it's hard to say what the movie's
about uh in in a single word or three
now it would just be like Tom Cruise
colon one with aliens
I'd probably do better
do better from the book of Tom Cruise
going to war part one honestly Tom
Cruise is a is IP at this point so it
should just be Tom Cruise
colon that's what I saw people were
talking about like well Indiana Jones
underperformed and like people thought
after top gun Maverick like all these
old Legacy sequels would do well and
it's like yeah but I don't know if
Indiana Jones their the brand identity
is not strong in 2023 whereas Tom Cruise
the brand identity is extremely they
didn't read the room these uh these
Boomers if they had done the mummy again
with Brandon Frazier that's a that's at
least a half a billion dollars yeah yeah
I think that it's weird and that would
cost less than half 35 Plus at this
point if you still care about it if you
still care about it sorry sorry
everybody yeah I'm I'm in that group I
don't blame me yeah I mean I didn't go
to see it but I liked it okay let's keep
going William cage a member of the
Army's Elite corporate fluff Brigade
lost my advertising firm
here I am he's facing every American's
worst nightmare waking up somewhere
unfamiliar and everyone is talking
European
chilling
but when his face gets melted with alien
time goo he'll be stuck reloading from
the same safe State over and over again
watch as he gets a little bit better
every time at avoiding work
we'll pause
in thinking about this bar I'm finding
it a little hard to believe
that Tom Cruise didn't find a loop where
he just got off the base and like went
to a pub or whatever and just like
didn't die because if you don't die the
loop is over
yeah he has to die to restart it so
we're saying that this sniveling PR Army
coward didn't find any any time frame
where he just walked like found a way
off the base to like go sit in a bar and
like not get shot in the head and go to
bed sometime right but no I think it can
keep going Beyond 24 there's no like cut
off like if it was three more days and
then he died it would go restart really
I think so I thought if he survives like
past 24 hours if he doesn't die if he if
he gets hurt and then something [__] up
his blood messes up his blood
before he died it's a blood thing it's a
blood thing right if he loses the time
blast the alien's blood is mixed with
his blood as long as he's got alien
blood in him I think he'll always
anytime he dies it'll respawn he
couldn't just like go off base and like
live uh there's one there is one day
where he goes off base and he goes to a
pub and remember those Old World War II
veterans are there hanging out talking
yeah and he says I've been there more
times than anyone he just then goes back
he doesn't like go AWOL permanently he
returns does he go have a life or is it
just he goes to sleep no he goes back to
the base that night and then at some
point someone shoots himself in the head
and then the day restarts yeah I don't
know about this I think there might be
there might be a timeline where maybe he
had an entire life and then dies and
then oh I'm back at the base no but the
world is like he doesn't I feel like the
war is going so badly that the world
doesn't have that long left I just think
that this this character like he
couldn't live another 40 years and the
war would just end I feel like this
character would have found a way to like
go to Samoa but then it's like he dies
it's gonna respawn anyways he's gonna
have to do it again he lives out the
entire plot of the movie Cocktail and
then he dies
against Wilford Brimley old he dies then
he goes back and responds on the base
again that's the beauty of time Loop
movies it's all the ones you miss you
know right um all right keep going
pitching his life story to strangers the
longer I talked more rational it's going
to appear the longer I talk the more
rationalized it's going to
appearing gay at Emily blood okay level
seven
ah so close Okay one more Loop she's
playing Rita bertaski a strong woman so
even if she Saves the World Anonymous
dudes are gonna call her yeah what has
she done for us lately thrill at this
amazing character who gets zero
backstory except for her middle name
tell me your middle name
until the moment of vulnerability where
we learn the hidden truth her real
middle name
oh but honestly who cares Emily Blunt
push-up yoga plus a big sword shoot me
in the face mommy just wait wait I think
I'm okay
oh well yeah this is actually play that
last part
it wasn't reset she's going to prison
yeah I always wondered what happened
after she shot Tom Cruise in the head
all those times did you have to just
explain the dead body
on the yeah or on the floor for training
or she just kills herself to that oh
that's Grim yeah she's not respawning so
it's like her Consciousness basically
dead ends wow that's a big risk the
first time you do it
every every time really yeah wow uh yeah
and then her character I mean it's just
a testament to the actress that she is
just like she was great she was great
she was great yeah and she did so much
with I think a very thin character
description yeah I feel like this was
the role Emily but like people already
liked Emily Blunt but she was like you
know she would be in like period movies
or rom-coms like Devil Wears Prada Emily
blood I feel like this was the one where
you could now put Emily Blunt in
anything and people will be like oh okay
now you know like we accepted her in all
these other genres like overnight
because she was so convincing in this
one and this um the uh the manga as I've
come to understand she's a much more
prominent character it's about the two
of them they can both loop at any time
or something like that and it's a lot
about their relationship and their back
and forth and their love and loss and
stuff like that so she gets a lot more
uh a backstory in in that
I feel like this works pretty well for
for him for a movie I'm glad this is
another one that we were talking about
before before the show about like you
know our movie for next week which I
won't specify it's a little long uh this
one's it it's like a full two hours I
think but it feels tight it doesn't feel
like it's drawn out it feels like you
get to everything and it's like paced
really well and I feel like that might
have that might have affected the pacing
I think it's a great one yeah the third
act like the whole last 30 40 minutes
even though and we have questions about
the ending and how it works um it's a
really it's really effective that they
they pull the rug out from under you
where like time Loops over
and that raises that's a great way to
raise the stakes in a Time Loop movie is
like oh you don't have that safety net
that we're relying on now or yeah for
the rest of it you've gotta you've got
it one last time yeah one life left
um all right keep going we'll get to
that part best in Humanity's war against
the mimic gimmick aliens who prove those
Flying Spaghetti Monster nerds were
right all along we'll throw everything
we've got at these hentai parodies of
Michael Bay's Transformers except for
using nukes missiles artillery tanks
Jets or non-europeans instead relying on
crappy neck suits with confusing
controls
oh
[Applause]
that run out of batteries in less than a
day
fall apart the moment you hit the ground
and sing like a stone in water
okay who got the government contract for
these death traps Tesla
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
Elon thank you that's so cool it's the
timing of it is so funny comedy all
right it's a fake robot everybody I mean
I guess the explanation in universe is
because it worked for Rita they think it
works for everyone like because she must
have single-handedly won that battle
that they're like okay this this is this
is working well yes they don't
understand the
mechanics of the time Loop thing so they
just think well if we put the right
badass and the right mech suit at the
right time we can win this thing yeah
and she just never told anyone well I
think
right it's like if there's no way to
tell people and not end up in a padded
room right so yeah I just don't tell
anything okay so there's your
explanation for why everyone's in these
completely shoddy yeah really really
glitchy individual like infantry Mech
suits but it's to add absolutely nothing
in terms of protection or strength or
anything it was all part of the the
brain bugs fiendish plan it was like let
them think they can win with their
stupid Mech suits and then we can easily
just roll right over the smart Brain
book
Neil Patrick Harris needs to put his
hand on there it's afraid it's afraid
Chargers are the best action thriller
that skips right to the good parts using
its time Loop premise as a narrative
fast forward button what next little uh
PT PT
because this is a training montage
disguised as a movie where cage goes
from regular slob to Super Soldier
faster than a sitcom actor joining the
MCU I'm not even trained for combat yeah
what's next
straight shot and even gets to plant all
of his elaborate heists off screen this
guy with the yellow armband always
recognizes you so just keep your head
down and stay to my right but to be fair
if you don't have Ryan Reynolds quipping
your ear off the whole time these things
do go a lot faster
check you don't have to do it I'm
standing right now I would
I would say that this is funnier than
red notice yeah or any really like
quippy well not every quippy action
movie but it's funny without having a
quipster in the entire cast because
they're they're reacted it's funny
because people are reacting organically
to the world the world around them in
their experience they're not like
letting you know that they're an actor
in a movie yeah reminding you that this
is a movie I I like Fletch the Chevy
Chase movie Fletch but we're in a period
where every movie is just trying to be
flexed Fletching out there's a movie
happening and then there's a guy
standing like outside the movie being
like look at this movie yeah I believe
these idiots in this movie and like
that's funny it when Fletch does it
because almost every other movie was not
like that right maybe like we're now in
a world where everyone wants to be
fletched all the time and uh some people
have to be Tim Matheson you can't all be
fledged I mean it is a reaction to I
think the bad guy the ultra sincerity of
I'd say 80s and 90s action Cinema which
was like like in Face-Off they are in
that movie yeah and obviously 80s action
movies like there is not a lick of humor
so I think this pendulum now has to
swing back the other way because in the
2000s in comic book film and everything
everyone has been meta and outside the
film and commenting on how crazy it is
and like I'm actually like literally on
Instagram right now in this movie
looking at things that you're looking at
on your couch and we're talking about
that yeah I'm just I'm right I think
we're all kind of tired of that like
super super tongue-in-cheek ironic
everything is like a wink wink elbow you
in the ribs that movies am I right and I
think yeah like that the the top gun
Maverick stuff to me like a lot of the
big movies that have been really
successful recently I feel like are that
like it's this more authentic experience
that's more but I'm just saying that
it's possible to make an action movie
with jokes with comedy in it without
resorting to a a smart alec uh rapid
talking Heist machine name name uh
what's that what's the red notice
character's name John Redd who even
knows yeah it's like Frank notice
no there's nobody's name though I don't
even careful there and rock you're gonna
crush your Tamagotchi did you remember
that did you really think I was gonna
remember Ryan Reynolds character's name
I mean you are a red noted I have no
Carter Carter notice Carter notice
and I think the Rock's name is John
something but it's a fake it's a fake
name because he's actually
um Bishop he's yes he's he's the he's
also he's half of the bit yeah yeah all
right go to the donut
I'm so sad I'm sad now are they is that
still happening are they making red
notice too is that like on hold Nolan
Booth how can you forget Nolan booth
well in Nolan Nola
oh and don't forget Soto voce oh first
Soto well that that's a whole character
now I
notices have a like character and their
their bit is there like vaguely foreign
like they're from they're from somewhere
else but like we can't they're not from
a specific foreign place they're just
like foreign
Reynolds annoying the rock for four
minutes straight I think that's a good
encapsulation of red numbers Ryan
Reynolds annoying me anyways Deadpool
three I can't wait uh all right keep
going
now if Cajun read it then somehow nailed
24 hours of chunky robot choreo huh okay
go
they'll blow up the mimic brain and go
back two days earlier because because uh
uh did I miss the loop that explains the
ending no well whatever we win
story I didn't even look into it I
haven't looked it up but I I have a
theory okay
so we see Cruz blows up the the mimic
brain and he dies but we see the the
blood again underwater we see the blood
so he's got the power again and with no
more alien he's the only one now with
the power so I think maybe
subconsciously he's got the power but
does he have the touch
yeah okay good see he met he went back
in time he met Stan bush
he now is has the ultimate control over
time Loop powers and whether consciously
or not in his dying moments he chose to
jump back too yeah I was wondering it's
like is that the day that the brain bug
resets to when the brain bug messes up
no I think now he's resetting time and
the brain bug is dead so he's just we're
gonna go retake that whole day but the
aliens are all mysteriously gone and
life can restart all right
the reason is because it's before he
goes AWOL and gets in trouble and so
it's all that gets blotted away he's a
major in good standing and that's why he
went back the extra day I think and then
he goes he still goes on to base to
stare at um well I think he's gonna try
to like hey hey I think he's gonna try
to start over and like see if he can get
this person to like him yeah all right
cool okay keep going
Tom and Tom again damn this blunt hits
hard hmm forbidden I I really hope that
somebody making a a mixtape uses that
sound bite damn
oh yeah that's good that's good anyways
uh carry on
That's it man take over man day over my
Tom can beat up your Tom that she's a
bit Sharon The Expendables and Tom
Cruise when he dreams about going to
therapy
ah
just take some nice Alien War at any
percent Speed Run new world record oh
wait let's see uh live die rename
Starship Loopers or how about Saving
Private dying wait wait nope groundhog
sleigh
there you go I like Groundhog's life
your name is Nance your Bibble
for it Skinner Griff this is only his
second time through the day and he
remembers everyone's name that's the
most impressive feed the whole film
I gotta say yeah given all the other
[__] that happened that day to be like
well Lon Frank it's true see more I feel
like I feel like Tom Cruise really does
this I feel like like this is how this
is how you you become Tom Cruise he's
like he's got a mnemonic device to
remember people's names he definitely
does that politician trick or whatever
yeah whatever he does he's got he's got
a Gary following him or he's just got
you know an ot7 in his ear uh in his
earpiece yeah like he's got a Luther in
the band this is Spencer Gilbert he
writes on his stream yeah he's got Benji
or Luther at all times yeah is in a van
outside of wherever Tom Cruise is going
speaking of which uh the Mission
Impossible by the numbers is out as well
uh go go check that video out you can
find out how many Luther man in the van
scenes there are there's a lot plus or
minus four yeah I feel like it's in Ving
rhames's contract that he doesn't have
to get out of this does not have to
stand at any point
um so yeah uh uh check that out uh hit
like And subscribe if you like more of
this we'll be doing more of it um and uh
let's watch some outtakes
so get ready for a Sci-Fi take on GI Joe
where knowing in advance is half the
battle that's basically just Starship
Troopers with time travel minus any
deeper message or satire this
the brain it controls them all but if
loving sci-fi Alien Invasion movies that
look exactly like World War II is wrong
who wants to be right we're fixing to
invade for us we need to figure out a
way to get us off that Beach tomorrow we
advance on the Western Front
story
Looper hero caged heat build a wall
despite all my rage I am still just a
time-hopping cage he's an act sir major
at
Jack repeater lovely Rita Rita Slade
Emily Blunt force trauma Emily in Paris
lovely reader massive blade Matrix
regurgitations Maniac Mansion returns
right I hate it myself killer Bill
action Paxton Sergeant Slaughter
Kentucky died Quicken and Commander bad
guy Moody soldiers a fortune teller
Third Eye Joe Black Max
Chrono triggered
Louvre actually
first weekend oh it's a terrific
presentation
terrific hey don't do the bit making fun
of how everyone has little multimedia
presentation set up to explain the movie
that's our bit
there you go really ripped off our bet
there yeah come on it's supposed to be
uh blank mix like blank checks not black
mix oh that must have been a type of it
I wonder if it doesn't really make sense
otherwise but okay whoops uh let's see
so
um let's get into the questions there's
some good ones here uh Luis Valenzuela
thoughts on the Wonka trailer I thought
it looked pretty good maybe Willy Wonka
origin could work I have not seen them
very well I thought I I didn't even know
they released real I just saw that image
of uh Timothy with the little Hugh Grant
Oompa Loompa in the in a little glass I
haven't even seen that that sounds great
it's real that's a real image real it's
spectacular yeah uh Benjamin is this the
longest time you've had between a
movie's release date and it's on his
trailer date and what do you think are
the most requested films that don't have
an Australia yet first question is no
because we've done plenty yeah we've
done stuff from the 70s
um the Japanese uh Spiderman Spiderman
Superman four
um
there's got to be if we ever what's the
oldest film I think we've done we gotta
do like Citizen Kane and we gotta get
into yeah we should do more like actual
classes I feel like maybe the first Star
Wars
for Star Wars yeah 77 that's probably
pretty early Jaws Mary Poppins like some
of the original Disney animators yeah
yeah okay yeah
yeah there you go yeah uh most requested
films that don't have it on Australia
yet I know like the Daredevil damn
Daredevil season one is like the number
one of all time yeah uh that might be
something related to Daredevil coming up
that we might we might uh break the
glass on that one and then um
gosh I don't know I don't know what's
the most requested yet yeah I feel like
if if Seth's requested for long enough
we we get to we just do it yeah we we
try to listen to you all yeah there's
some someone keeps requesting the League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen oh yeah I
think I have seen that that would be
that would be fun but I just it nobody
maybe who remembers it who somebody
didn't remember there will be a week
where it's like well what else is
happening nothing all right League of
extraordination but I don't remember why
it's yeah I haven't seen it
um so I rewatched it in many years uh
Samuel Furman um swap the lead roles for
Barbie and Oppenheimer which are you now
more excited to see
wow I I I'm gonna go ahead and say I
strongly feel like Margot Robbie's
Oppenheimer could play J Robert
Oppenheimer in a way that was
interesting I'm not convinced Killian
Murphy could could be Barbie maybe he's
a talented guy I don't know I would be
probably more interested to see how he
pulls it off
um because I feel like Margot Rob
Margo's Oppenheimer I don't know I feel
like the the Nolan no offense but he can
kind of flatten the actors into kind of
like the place he wants them to be where
it's like what if she did look very
haunted what if she did Oppenheimer
entirely in the Harley Quinn voice
though
Mr Einstein
I don't know if the cards
have I sold you
just like swinging a big Mallet yeah on
uh on um now I have become dead
uh
uh so oh bringing it back around lose
Vons way let you guys see the Deadpool
three photos we got the yellow spandex
we did it we did it we did it folks
cinema achieved did you see that there
there there's apparently a scene where
Deadpool and Wolverine are fighting in
those in their in their iconic comic
book outfits in front of like a Planet
of the Apes dystopian 20th century fight
like they have a 20th Century Fox logo
that's like crumbling and so it's it's I
feel like we know what the whole the
whole bit is it's like he kills the
kills the fox the studio yeah Universe
you know look
I I think we've been too harsh on Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool because I do think
that it is the best maybe one of the
better executions of the metahumor genre
is Deadpool uh the first the first
Deadpool sure oh yes and it's like a
good match of actor and roll Etc it's
the problem is that every of everything
has become Deadpool right it's not
Deadpool's fault that everyone else
wants to be dead I am become Deadpool
Destroyer Phil yeah um so that's the
thing is that dead deadpooling has
become a genre of film and a genre of
character that we're sick of
um yeah so I'm you know hopefully they
bring something new to it but the fact
that it's like
remember this you know who who are they
talking about bringing back Jennifer
Garner's electricians returning and it's
like that is I'm sorry I lived through
Elektra that is nothing I am not excited
I'm assuming you know it'll be a joke
about how everybody hated those movies
but like we
we got that we we did that with Green
Lantern already we did that we just did
it with Amazing Spider-Man and like I'm
just like the problem about comedy is
it's only funny the first time yeah so
you want to keep trying that's why
comedy sequels are usually never good
because they're repeating the same jokes
yeah this is just the same bit we've now
seen a bunch of times and meanwhile this
is episode 500 and something of on
Australia's commentaries
we'll keep making them if you keep on
that's right we're Hypocrites uh all
right let's move on to another question
um let's see James Bond what major life
event would you want to be stuck in the
same day over and over again wow is
there a day of your life that you'd be
like yeah none uh I mean I guess you
know like there were some days better
than better than others today was a good
day yeah like I don't like not a work
day I would pick like a vacation day or
you know like I took a I took a cruise
one so we went to to sit Martin uh I
spent the whole day you know like by by
a beach like in the Caribbean like that
that was a nice day but by Loop 10 000
you're like can I get like a burger I'm
sure you get a burger you could get a
beer but I'm just saying maybe I would
not pick an island
yeah that's true although self-contained
Adventure like that's the sort of thing
like you would you would Groundhog Day
you would meet everyone on that island
and get to know them really well and
like it would become like a community in
in one day for you now the time Loop
premise as you know it's based on the
nietzschian idea of Eternal recurrence
sure so that is the um the thing that
I'm gonna mangle it but it's the idea
that you should live every day as if you
have to live that day eternally for the
rest of your life and that is the
standard that you should hold your days
to yeah which seems like a lot of work
Mitch it does yeah really a lot of those
old philosophers had like these very
exacting like like if you read a manual
Conte it's like this formula for
everything you've got to do right am I
is this action moral or not you have to
like take all these things into
consideration like I got I gotta say my
manual you could just sit around all day
and think about this stuff but I got a
job I do now just hearing that name want
to see um Emmanuel uh swapping out the
Emmanuel Cinemax yeah serious Emmanuel
in space it's just like a weird little
German guy going to space and he's got
lots of opinions
philosophy
I think of outer space sensuality
so
all right one more question fine I wanna
I wanna I wanna sign off on that but um
luckily we've got the smartest most
erudite audience in the internet they're
loving they're loving this uh Kanti and
philosophy
um James uh let's end with um benzite 10
what's your favorite Tom Cruise stunt
and what do you think is the most
impressive one great question I feel
like in the theater I don't know if it's
number one but in the theater or if when
you saw it in IMAX Ghost Protocol with
the outside the the skyscraper in Dubai
sequence yeah that's a real showstopper
sequence because you get that that
vertigo tightness in your chest feeling
of being really high up and he you know
like it really it's visceral in a way I
think a lot of other scenes maybe to me
it's it's the breath holding one because
that's that's just insane like I can
fathom you know skydiving or having to
um hang off of a building just given
like normal human capabilities but
holding your breath for that long while
you're doing an action scene as an actor
was also gave me that like class phobia
I'm drowning feeling yeah but my
favorite one is still the first mission
impossible rope hang when he's the knock
stealing the knock list right because
there's just so many things going on
with the floor and the bead of sweat and
the rat with genre
such a a master a master of suspense one
of the greatest living suspense
filmmakers and yeah it's just like a
signature sequence and that the Silence
of it where you just like right oh so
good so that's my favorite that's still
my favorite uh all right
um next week we'll be back we'll be back
with a blockbuster film
[Music]
um the culmination of a long journey and
a long film that yeah there's been a lot
of big movies this year that I feel like
have underwhelmed and this this is one
that didn't yeah it was definitely a
rare one that I think satisfied what we
wanted I was definitely satisfied maybe
even over satisfied you know it's like
when you make a mixtape like maybe keep
it to 12 Songs instead of like 21
because you know gotta tell them how you
feel through song and maybe like you're
kind going on a little little rambly but
still enjoyable we'll be back next week
for that thanks for watching on
Australia's commenters bye-bye
[Music]
foreign